all right as outrage grows over New York
city mayor Eric Adams handing out free
prepaid debit cards to illegal
immigrants and the 180 some odd million
that he's now allocating towards you
know more hotel rooms the mayor decided
to set the record straight today at a
hearing in Albany and let the world know
that's exactly what he's doing take a
look there's one thing I learned in New
York New York New Yorkers are very
opinionated and they share their
thoughts and so first we want to dismiss
the Mis misinformation uh we're not
giving people American Express cards we
found that the food delivery service
that we set up during the emergency we
could find a better way to do it in our
belief that we want to cut 20% of the
migrant cost so we have a pilot project
with 500 people that we are giving them
a food card so instead of a debit card
instead of having to deliver food and
have people eat food that we were seeing
waste in food they're now able to get
their own food that is going to be spent
$12 a
day and 500 people get 53 million that's
not all a couple of days ago Adams
decided that it was a good time to brag
about his staff's diversity he did it in
his own way take a look stand up stand
up they need to see you Deputy Mayor
Williams isim Deputy Mayor miror Josie
Deputy Mayor amazar Deputy Mayor Maria
Torres
springler have you ever seen this much
chocolate leading the city of New
York and then go down the line look look
who's here this is representative of the
city that's why people are hating on
me oh that's why the fanny Willis
defense anyway joining us live he's on
the streets to New York City former Mar
oral candidate Curtis Lea is with us uh
so okay
uh he likes chocolate over vanilla it
sounds like sound a little like L faran
to me there uh $53 million in debit
cards for 500 people on top of 180
million for more hotel rooms uh in New
York uh on top of the 1 billion that
Biden has given people that enter our
country illegally uh and we saw what
happened to the people on tape beating
the hell out of two police officers
Curtis things getting better in New York
City
absolutely not in fact that's why I'm
his number one hater join the Curtis Lea
Haters Club of Eric Adams who is
single-handedly destroying this city by
giving illegal aliens everything they
arrive in our city imagine you check
into your hotel you get conier service
and Bam you get
,000 debit card that you can use for the
whole month and you get more money than
any veteran any homeless person any
emotionally disturbed person in New York
City gets that's an absolute outrage and
this may it just doesn't seem to get it
he takes care of the illegal aliens and
forsakes his own people especially the
africanamerican porn impoverished who
elected him mayor of the city of New
York over me Curtis
leward yeah well by the way if you
divide 53
million by 500 that's
$16,000 debit card not a bad deal I
don't think they giving them to to vets
that are homeless in New York City not
that I've heard
Curtis well fact car guys have just
taken down one of the migrant guys right
here on the corner 42nd and 7th while
all this can you Pan the camera they've
taken over they've taken over you like
the camera over there F all
possible yep
you got your key open
guys is out of control out of
control hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else